my biggest fashion fail at the time was  a success in retrospect was a huge  failure it was the the number where you  you know when you do this little thing  and then you fold it then you roll it  God everybody loved the 80s didn't they  real men should never wear the sweater  vest the suit vest over like a t-shirt  that's sort of i'm kind of loose and  with it ready for anything kind of look  and then the vest with absolutely  nothing on underneath that it's that so  that's a right to jail every man should  own aviators as taught to me by the  Guru's here at GQ if i could only wear  one thing for the rest of my life what  what i choose it would babe baby it  would be my wedding ring i love you so  much really hoping to get laid tonight